[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN CARMEL:
Well, thank you.
I'm Jonathan Carmel.
I'm a product manager
for Android Instant Apps,
and you've come to the
session for an introduction
to Instant Apps.
So, I'm really excited to
highlight a lot of the partners
that we have live today,
many are in the audience.
But before we dive
into that, let's talk
about the foundation of Instant
Apps, which are Android apps.
We love Android apps.
Android apps are getting
better and better.
They are fast,
seamless, beautiful,
and take advantage of
device capabilities.
Let's take a look at some of
them on my home screen today.
We have Ticketmaster,
who has a beautiful end
to end experience.
So let's say I wanted to
go see LCD Soundsystem.
Well, I would just
go into Ticketmaster,
I would search for
LCD Soundsystem.
And due to NDK's support
and their seat view,
I can find the
exact seat I want,
see what it looks like in the
venue, and buy right there.
Next day, I can actually get
into the concert with my phone.
Then you have Citymapper, which
has saved me a lot this week,
because I'm actually staying
in a Mountain View hotel.
And I'm riding my bike
because I didn't want
to hit the traffic you all hit.
It's a 30 minute
bike ride and I have
no idea how to navigate the
backwoods of Mountain View.
So, I open up Citymapper,
tells me the exact transit,
and due to the map
view support, I
can dive in and figure out
that turn that I just missed
and go back a few miles.
Then you have Red Bull
TV, a lean back experience
for immersive television.
All of these add up
to great Android apps.
All of you in the crowd
have done an amazing job
developing apps, but
you told us in order
to get that experience
you first have to install.
And there's a friction
point, and you
don't have as many users
using your best experience.
So what if we could have
that same experience,
but with just with a
click you dive into it?
And that is Android
Instant Apps.
They are native Android
apps that run instantly
without installation.
So let me dive into a
very simple example.
I have a friend Joyce
and she loves Buzzfeed.
She's on the BuzzFeed
app all the time just
looking through videos.
The other day she told me
that there are seven ways
to make chicken wings.
Now you and I all know,
that there are only six ways
to make chicken wings.
So, I usually would have to
download the BuzzFeed video
app from the Play Store, wait,
open it up, and then search
for the video she's
talking about.
But now, all I have to
do, she sends me a link,
all I have to do is click, I
dive right into the native app
experience.
And unfortunately, I find out
there are actually seven ways
to make chicken wings.
Now I might not want
to use Buzzfeed.
I just want that experience
right then and there.
I don't necessarily want
to save it to my phone,
and with Instant Apps you
don't necessarily have to.
So let's talk about a few of our
additional live partners today
that I'm really
excited to talk about.
The first one is Dotloop, which
is a contract signing app.
I don't sign
contracts every day,
but when I get that email
that says, "Time sensitive,
you have to sign this contract
right now," and I'm in transit,
I don't want to have to wait to
get back to my desktop to sign.
Don't worry, Dotloop
has you covered.
They have this beautiful
native app experience
that really guides you
through the flow, telling you
how many signatures you have
to have in the contract.
Having you read, flip through
the contract, and then dive
into the exact place
you have to sign.
Now early results for
Dotloop have been phenomenal.
They're seeing more users
start that experience.
There's double digit uplift for
just starting that experience
because they're guiding
you immediately,
and then they're seeing double
digit increase for the number
of signed contracts.
HotPads is another
Instant App that's live,
and it's a real
estate browsing app.
Now, my wife and I are
looking to move right now.
Or at least I believe
so, because she
keeps on sending me links
every day about new properties.
So, I don't have the
HotPads app on my phone,
but she does because
she's browsing properties
all the time.
But now when she
sends me a link,
I dive into this high
fidelity experience,
get to flip through
all the photos,
look at the dimensions
of that home,
look at a lot of rich
textual information,
like what schools are nearby.
And then I can flip through new
houses that I'm interested in,
and when I'm ready, I actually
can contact the broker
and set up times to
actually see the house.
And that's exactly what HotPads
is trying to optimize for.
They want you to reach
out to the broker
and actually see the house.
And HotPads told us that they've
been optimizing their app
for over 12 years, and to
see the uplift they're seeing
right now is significant.
Let's talk about my
new daily ritual,
morning ritual, which is
New York Times crossword.
I wake up in the morning,
I do a quick search
to find the New York
Times crossword,
I open it up in google.com and
it shows a little instant badge
right next to it.
I dive into the
instant app experience,
and I get to finish the
crossword immediately.
And every day I send my
best time to my whole team,
this is the time to
beat for the day.
Now, early data shows
that I'm not alone.
That this has become
more habitual for users
in the Instant App.
They are coming
back more and more,
and they're seeing significant
increases in reengagement
from early data.
I'm very excited to
put this slide up.
Today we have 50 partners live.
So I want to thank
all the partners that
have worked so hard to get
these Instant Apps live today.
So please give them
around of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
We have 15 Instant Apps
from 14 different countries.
And you can see, we cover a
bunch of different categories.
And I'll just go
through a few of them,
I'm sorry I'm leaving
some of you out,
but you can see e-commerce
partners like Jet, Wish,
and Ticketmaster.
You can see entertainment, like
Vimeo, Red Bull, Viki, TabPro,
and New York Times crossword.
TabPro is great if you
ever want to learn guitar.
You have news and
publishing apps,
like CBC, One
Football, and Pocket.
And you have travel apps,
like TripIt, Skyscanner,
and Citymapper.
Over the last year,
these partners
have been extensions
of our product team.
They're not only trying to
optimize their instant app,
but they're also giving
us tons of feedback
on the platform and the
tooling that we have in place.
So a lot of the tooling
that you'll check out today
is due to all the hours of
feedback they provided for us.
So, I really want to thank them
again, and today at 4:30 p.m.
you'll see a panel where
you hear from the developers
themselves.
Now let's take all these apps
and put them on our phone.
Even the apps
today, that is a lot
of apps to fit on your phone.
But thankfully,
these native apps
are now part of your phone.
You can access them
anytime, anywhere,
even if it's not
installed on your phone.
Now yesterday, you heard that
anyone can now build an Instant
App, so we're really excited
to open up to all of you
and start seeing more and more
of you develop Instant Apps.
You can now access
the documentation,
download the SDK, and
download the tooling.
So what should you
expect when you start
developing an Instant App?
One code-base, one
project, and the tools
you are already familiar with.
You will develop an Android 3.0.
The first step you'll do is
begin to modularize your app,
and start taking the features
that you already have today
and breaking it up into
different feature modules.
And we have the tooling to
help you do that and lead you
along the way, and we
stress the reuse of code
from the installable app.
So you're again working in
one code-base, one project.
When you're done you
upload to the Play console.
Now, you will not have to go
and hire an Android Instant Apps
engineer.
This is the Android development
you are already familiar with.
And when we talked
to our 50 partners,
and asked them how
long did it take
them to develop an Instant App?
All apps vary, but they
said on average it's
about four to six weeks.
So, let's talk about how
you prepare your use case.
One thing I'll stress
throughout this presentation
is the importance of
focusing on the action you're
trying to get the users to do.
So, I know that many of you
are focused on installations,
but really what you're trying
to do when you developed
your Android app
and your instant app
is get the user to read
an article, watch a video,
sign a contract, do a purchase
get highly engaged in your app.
That is your goal.
So what are some
of the motivations
that we have seen and heard
from our early partners
about why they developed
an instant app?
We'll break them into
three categories.
The first one is about focusing
on your current user base
and optimizing their
experience, and that's
what we call conversion.
The second one is
thinking about new users
that you can now reach.
And the third one is
completely new use cases.
So again, for conversion we
think about your current users
and were thinking--
when we say conversion
we mean what metric are you
really trying to optimize?
So for your current
users, many of you
have told me that your native
app is one of your best
properties and you want more
users going to your native app.
So, of your current
user base, you're
actually opening
up accessibility
of your current user
base to actually dive
into that native app.
So we launched
recently with Jet,
and they're seeing great numbers
of the likelihood of a user now
purchasing when they
land on the Instant App
has increased significantly
by double digits.
Reach is about
top of the funnel,
reaching more users that haven't
even seen your property before.
This is true for a lot
of app first developers.
So you can imagine
for a lot of app
first developers they're
thinking, "Most of my discovery
happens on the Play Store.
I'm getting most of my
users from installed users."
And the question is, can we
expand that surface area?
Can we reach new users that you
haven't reached in the past?
And if you're thinking
about now you URLs as a way
to onboard into your
experience, you're
basically increasing
that surface area
across the internet
for new users
to actually interface with
your native app experience.
We've seen this
especially with Castbots.
For a podcast,
oftentimes I listen to it
actually every day.
I listen to a podcast
and I love Castbots.
And I don't always want to
share my podcasts with people,
because I'm not sure if
they listen to podcasts,
and I don't know what
their experience is
going to look like.
But now when I
share a URL, I know
that they're going to dive
right into that same native
experience that
I'm experiencing,
and I know that's
a great experience.
So my propensity to
share has increased.
Finally, there are new
use cases that we're
excited to see what
the people in this room
start to think about and
develop now that there's
no install friction,
and there's not
as much friction between the
physical and digital world.
So you can imagine, when you go
to a baseball game, a museum,
and you want a map for
the day, you're not
likely to install an app.
Or if you go to
the baseball game
and you have an option to
order food to your seat,
but you're like, "I don't
want to install an app,
I'm just going to go to
the concession stand."
We've removed a lot
of that friction,
so there are opportunities
to on-board users.
And we're thinking here,
things like QR codes,
beacons, NFC, new ways to get
the user into your experience.
Now we've been calling
this companion apps,
and we're really excited
to see what you guys all
develop in this room.
If you go to our
sandbox today, you'll
actually see some of
our early partners
actually developing these
type of experiences.
So at this point,
hopefully you're
now excited and
motivated to start
developing an Instant App.
So what should you
start thinking about
alongside the development?
What are the guiding
principles that
will help you develop
an Instant App?
There are five
guiding principles.
The first one is
the idea of one app.
We like to think of Instant
Apps and installed apps
as one app that run in
two different modes.
I often like to compare
Instant Apps to the streaming
version of music.
You're breaking up
the albums into songs,
and then streaming each song.
It's very similar to what
you'll do with Instant Apps.
When you're on the plane, you
download music to your phone
so you have offline access.
But when you're
sitting at home, you
don't think about what music
do I have in my phone today?
You're actually just
accessing all the music
that you have access to, and
you're not thinking, "Oh, I
have to download this or not."
So going back to
the one app concept,
we want to think of Instant
Apps as the same app,
only being used on demand.
From an engineering
standpoint, that's
exactly what it will feel like.
Again one code-base,
one project,
all the features you already
use your installed app
in your Instant App.
And Android Studio 3.0,
we ensure just that,
with high code reuse
between your installed app
and your Instant App.
Now again, we'll go in depth
into the actual development
of an Instant App at
our technical session
later at 3:30 p.m. which I
encourage you all to go to.
And there will actually
develop an instant app
live in less than 40 minutes.
But as you can see here,
just from this diagram,
all the features from
your installed app
are now present in
your Instant App.
And all that you've
done is broken them
up so that now the user can
access feature one module,
would not necessarily having
to download and install
a feature to module.
But from an installed
app standpoint,
its the same app
at the same output.
And so it's the same experience
from your installed app.
Nothing's changed.
From the user standpoint, you're
thinking about the same UI,
navigation, and flows.
A lot of developers
ask me, "Should I just
develop a trial app?"
That is not the goal.
You should not be thinking of
developing a trial Instant App.
Trying back on
the music analogy,
ideally the user
doesn't know if there
in an Instant App
or installed app,
because the content is the same.
All those rich experiences
and all those great
features that you have
in your installed app,
you want to pull over
to your Instant App.
And it's really important,
because if a user ever
goes from your Instant
App to your installed app,
you want as little
relearning as possible.
There's no on-boarding process.
The user already knows
what this app does and they
understand all your features.
And we've received a
lot of positive data
for Vimeo, which I think
has done a great job.
They pulled all their features
into their Instant App,
and they're seeing that of users
coming to their experience,
they stay longer,
they go deeper,
and they get more engaged.
And so they've also seen double
digit increase in engagement.
The next three
sections, I'll talk
about what happens once
you're in an Instant App.
So let's enter the app.
Before you might have thought of
having one flow, because you're
downloading, let's
say, a monolithic app,
and there's only one flow
that the user can go through.
That's now changed
with Instant Apps.
You've actually, now think
about side entry points
into your Instant App.
So you have to think about
what that flow feels like.
If someone just sends
me an URL, and I
don't know exactly what the
Instant App is going to be,
and I click it, if I hit
a sign up flow, I'm like,
I might be surprised.
I might not understand
what the actual value
proposition is for that app.
So you want to think of
where across the internet
a user could actually
enter the app.
Through text, social media, ads,
all these different mechanisms
that a user can come in.
And what is the context when
they actually click that app?
And you want to
account for that when
you're thinking about the flow.
If someone sends me a recipe, I
want to drop into that recipe.
If someone sends
me a video, I want
to drop into the exact video.
Search integration is also
present in Instant Apps,
so you want to think about
what happens when a user lands
into your page from a search.
Here, I actually did a
search of my hometown
in Franklin, Michigan,
and you see Zillow come up
three times as an Instant App.
So what has Zillow done?
They said, "You're
searching for this area,
you're probably
interested in a property.
I'm going to make sure
my instant app dives you
into a specific property
on Sunset Drive."
And there are three
relevant properties for me.
I click that link,
and I dive right
into the native app experience.
Now, side entry is
important, but you're also
going to have to think
about home entry still.
This was shown at the
developer keynote yesterday,
of actually getting to use
the Android O, integration
with launcher, allows
you to launch Instant
Apps from the home screen.
So here, you can
see I typed in NY,
it gives me a
recommendation of New York
Times crossword Instant App.
I click that, or actually I
pull that onto my home screen,
and now when I click
it, it actually
dives me into the home screen
of the crossword puzzle.
It doesn't dive me directly
into the crossword puzzle,
because it's thinking about
the context of the user,
and I'm driving into the home
screen of that native app.
So oftentimes, when we
think about Instant Apps,
we think about install friction.
But there's friction
that we're trying
to solve with Instant
Apps across the native app
experience.
We want to remove all
friction points that we've
heard from developers.
So sign in is one, where I
mentioned a few slides ago
where sometimes you're asked
to sign in when you have
no idea what the app is about.
Other times, with
purchasing, you
might not have a
credit card around,
and yet you still
want to purchase.
How can we remove those
friction points from apps?
So, as I mentioned
before sign in sometimes
happens upfront with monolithic,
or with installable apps,
because you've already gone
through a friction point,
you know exactly the user flow
that user is going through,
so you decide to have
them sign in upfront.
But when users are coming
through the side entry,
you might not want a sign
in to happen right then.
So we've actually had a
number of our partners
who in their installed app
had mandatory sign in upfront,
had removed that, and
decided to put sign
in at a point in the
flow where they felt
that the user understood why
they would be signing in,
and the value of signing in.
Instant Apps also
uses Smart Lock
for Android, which
allows you to continue
to be signed in between
Android, Chrome, and desktop.
Sorry, Chrome and
Chromebooks, as well as being
continued to be signed in
between Instant App sessions.
For purchasing, there's
digital purchasing
and physical purchasing.
Digital purchasing is very
similar to what you experience,
or it's identical to what you
experience in installed app.
There's in app billing
that you'll continue
to use with Instant Apps.
For physical purchases,
we're actually
really excited to talk
about Google payment API.
Some of you may have already
heard about it in the developer
keynote where
assistant mentioned it,
and there was also another
session specifically
talking about the
Google payment API.
We're really excited to have
this as part of Instant Apps.
So there are
hundreds of millions
of cards that Google
already has on file,
and when you're thinking about
a user now entering a Instant
App, a lot of time
there are new users,
they might not have
a form of payment
or a credit card on
file with you yet.
But they potentially have a form
of payment on file with Google.
Now they can access
that Google payment API
and access that credit card.
Here you see that Jet is
using this Google payment API,
and I just click pay and
the Google Pay shows up.
It already has my
credit card information,
it already has my
shipping information,
and with just a few clicks I'm
already done with my purchase.
So when I mentioned before
that Jet is seeing an increase
propensity for users to purchase
when they land in the Instant
App, and they're seeing
these great numbers, what
I'm wondering is, how much that
is from the decreasing install
friction, and how much is it
from decreasing the payment
friction?
And as we get more
and more data,
I'm really excited to parse that
out and really understand how
much value is coming from each.
But right now, as
Jet has told us,
they're seeing significant
increase in purchases.
I also wanted to
say, I mentioned
that we don't want you adding
additional friction points.
And with our early partners,
we did a lot of testing,
we tried different stuff out.
And we realized that the
thing we wanted to do
is get the user to that
action that they came
to do as quickly as possible.
Some early partners
tried splash screens,
others tried a lot of
installation prompts,
and we just think getting rid
of all these friction points
allows for a very
smooth experience.
So, the users had
this great experience
in their Instant App.
They've really enjoyed
it, and now they
want to install for
a number of reasons,
maybe they want to
do offline usage.
That is fine.
We actually encourage
installation in that case.
So let's talk about what
that experience looks
like when a user
chooses to install.
First of all, we've actually
decreased the friction point
of installing in
the Instant App.
There's this new API,
play install API,
that allows you to
install in line when
you're in an Instant App.
So in this case, I'm
playing a Red Bull video,
watching some BMXer, and I
think this video is awesome,
and I really want to have
this for offline usage.
So I install there,
and it allows
me to install online without
having to go to the Play Store.
What you also want to
take into account is,
copying that user information
from the Instant App
to the installed app, so you
know what their, in this case,
their video history was,
and you can actually
put them right back into the
video they were watching when
they hit open installed app.
Now, let's talk about the
ways that you can actually
prompt the user to install.
There are two ways.
The first one is
explicit installations.
This means that the
user knows that they're
about to install if they
hit that button, because it
says install.
The second one is
implicit installations.
These are when you click a
button in the Instant App,
and the feature might
not be available,
like offline viewing,
so you prompt
the user, "If you'd like to use
this feature, please install."
So let's talk about
both tools that we
have for driving installation.
The first one, as I mentioned,
is an explicit installation,
you include the install
string and the install icon
here, that you can see the Amber
Weather did a great job with.
And they embedded in their UI,
what is Amber Weather thinking?
Well, they want the user to get
the information that came for,
which is the weather.
They want to show all these
great things that they
have within their app, but now
if the user wants to install,
the button is right
there, but it feels really
part of their UI.
Wish does a great
job of including it
in their navigation tour.
It's not disruptive, and
it's very easy for the user
if they want to install,
to install right there.
Implicit installations,
as I mentioned,
is when you click a
button in the Instant App,
and that feature is
not yet available.
Vimeo, for example,
has offline viewing,
and Yumly has some
personalized information,
personalized things that
they do that they would only
like in the installed app.
That's great, that's fine.
So here, you see that it
prompts the user to install,
and it gives context to why
the user has to install.
Again, early partners have
tried both explicit and implicit
installations.
We just encourage you not
to make it disruptive,
and for the user to
really know, to be
able to do the action
they came to do.
And if they choose to
continue and potentially want
to install, that you give
them an option to do so.
So, you've built this amazing
app, this amazing Instant App,
that mirrors your installed app.
You have thought about
all the different entry
points and the
different flows that
are important to account for.
And you've thought about
decreasing friction
from identity, to
payments, to installation.
So now you're ready
to track your success.
What does that look like?
Well, first you need to
upload your Instant App
to the Play console.
This is going to feel very
similar to your installed app.
We have three different tracks.
There's the development
track, the pre-release ,
track and the prod track.
And this allows you to
do some testing upfront
and make sure that you're
ready for production.
Also, the latest
update that you push
will go directly to your users.
We'll serve it
directly to the users,
so if they click that URL, you
get the updated Instant App.
We're also big proponents
of experimentation.
So we included something
called the mobile hold-back.
And we love this
idea, this allows
you to hold back a
percentage of your traffic
to go to the mobile web.
So if I put in to 0.2,
20% of your traffic
will go to the mobile web,
and 80% of your traffic
will go to Instant Apps.
This enables you to do
testing and experimentation.
We know that you've optimized
for years and years,
your native app experience.
You've optimized
your mobile website,
and you've optimized
your desktop.
And we want to make sure
we give you the tools
to now optimize Instant Apps,
and try to make it the best
property that you can.
So let's talk about now,
what type of metrics
you'll now be tracking
in the Instant App that
might be different than
how you thought about
with installed apps.
So I've chosen to flows up here.
One is where you start in an
installed app with the Play
Store.
You install your app,
you then sign up,
you then browse and engage with
the content of the native app,
and then potentially purchase.
For Instant Apps, a few
things start to flip around.
First you're entering the
Instant App from a URL.
You're then immediately
engaged without signing up,
and you actually can
purchase without signing up
for the e-commerce category, and
you won't necessarily install.
So you have to start
thinking about, what
are different metrics that
you now track that are
important in Instant Apps.
First, you probably want
a separate installed apps
and Instant Apps
when you're tracking,
just to see different behavior.
Maybe a user who's a first
visitor for your installed app
acts differently for your first
visit for your Instant App,
and that's because
you're actually
creating different flows.
The user might be coming
through a side door,
so that user in that context
might act differently.
You also might now think
about signed in users
versus non-signed in users.
So some of our partners
only had signed in users
before, and now that they've
pulled that out or moved it
to a different point
in their Instant App,
they're going to have
non-signed in users.
You also have to think about
URL traffic sources, which
you might not have
considered in the past.
Now.
Google Analytics for
Firebase has you covered.
We've worked for months with
Google Analytics for Firebase
to make sure that
all of these metrics
start to be tracked
for your Instant App.
They are continuing to work with
us to put additional tracking
and think through different
additional complex metrics that
make sense in Instant Apps.
For our early
partners, a lot of them
have actually used their
current analytics SDK.
So now that we're opening
documentation today,
we were excited to talk to
more analytics providers
and start thinking
about more metrics
that we need to start
including in the SDK.
So, with all that these
partners have shared with me,
I've noticed actually a shift.
When they first started
with Instant Apps
they often talked to
me about installation,
and there has been a
shift in our conversation
where we talk a lot
more about engagement.
Because as I showed
in the flow before,
it used to be that in order
to see your success metrics,
you would have to install first.
So an installation became
a proxy for success,
but we've kind of flipped that
around, and now developers are
saying, "How do I optimize
the tickets purchased?
How do I optimize
the flights found?
How about watch hours?
And how about time spent
reading football articles?"
So all of this
has changed a bit,
and we're excited to
see how you guys start
thinking about metrics
in a different way.
So, let's recap.
First, I talked through
that anyone can now
build an Instant App.
So you can go to
g.go/instantapps and download
the SDK and view
the documentation.
Secondly, I talked about
what the big motivation
is for partners
developing an Instant App.
It's thinking about
your current users,
thinking about new
users, and thinking
about completely new use cases.
The third thing I talked
about, is what should you
keep in mind as guiding
principles as you in parallel
do development?
Talked about one app,
different entry points,
decreasing friction
from identity,
to payments, to installation,
as well as new metrics.
There are two talks
that I'd really
encourage you to go to today.
The first one is at 3:30,
with Shobana and Anirudh
will be actually taking you
through a live Instant App
development in 40 minutes.
So it's really
exciting, and I really
encourage you to learn
how they're actually
going to take an
installed app and turn it
into an Instant App.
Also, I've done my best to
channel the developer voice
from talking to all
our early partners,
but it's much better to hear
directly from our partners.
So I encourage you to
go to Maru's talk, who's
the lead Developer Relations
Manager for Instant Apps,
and she'll have on the panel,
Castbots, Vimeo, Deliveroo,
Zillow, and
Periscope, and they'll
talk about their experience,
and you'll learn best practices.
So, thank you everyone.
I'm so glad you all came.
I'm happy to take any questions
from you now, and also
please visit us
in sandbox Dome C,
and I'll be there also to
answer additional questions
after the talk.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
as